well it begins Donald Trump paid zero in
taxes in 2020 claimed a 5 million dollar
refund and the big picture of Trump's
taxes that has come out based on a
report we have we don't yet have the tax
returns but we have a report about the
tax returns from the house Ways and
Means Committee is just about everything
that we suspected everything that we
suspected and we're going to talk about
it so let's start with the big picture
data let's look at Trump's income
taxable income and taxes paid over the
last six years in 2015 Trump reported an
income loss of nearly 32 million dollars
paid had zero taxable income and paid
six hundred and forty thousand dollars
in taxes in 2016 Trump says he lost 31
million dollars had zero taxable income
and paid 750 dollars not 750 000. 750
dollars in taxes 2017 Trump claimed
negative income of 13 million dollars
paid 750 dollars in taxes in 2018 Trump
claimed a taxable income of 23 million
and paid about a million in taxes on
that 2019 Trump claimed about 3 million
dollars in taxable income and paid a
little over 100k in taxes and then in
2020 Trump reported a loss of nearly 5
million dollars and paid
0.0 in federal taxes claiming a refund
of
5.47 million dollars there's a good CNBC
write-up called read how much Trump paid
or didn't pay in taxes each year uh it
outlines the numbers that I just
mentioned with a number of other
elements including
um that the tax returns we're ultimately
going to get are redacted and it may
actually still be difficult to figure
out
how Trump got to these negative income
claims Etc
um the most important thing that I think
is is worth mentioning here is that most
of this stuff is almost certainly legal
and what we're really getting to here is
the failure of the IRS despite all these
claims that the IRS is predatory and
they've got all these armed people which
they really did they have very few armed
people and it's not a big deal that some
of the people are armed despite all the
claims about the IRS the IRS really has
failed us not even auditing Trump in his
required automatic audit that presidents
get
until they caught wind that Richard Neal
in the house Ways and Means Committee
was trying to obtain these tax returns
then they said oh we'd better do that
audit on Trump which we were supposed to
have done already for several years so a
few different aspects to this is it
possible that Trump's taxes will expose
crimes absolutely they look like they
would be along the fraud lines stating
different asset values for the same
assets depending on whether he's trying
to avoid property taxes or personal
taxes versus get a loan using those
assets as collateral we already suspect
and in fact we know based on what
happened the ruling with Trump's uh
business of 17 guilty counts I guess it
was two weeks ago we already know that
that was done at the business level
almost certainly being done at the
personal level the taxes will help to
build that case are there potential
National Security issues as a result of
some of the people Trump is in League
with absolutely the tax returns could
very well expose that but what's really
important to understand is that Trump's
not the only rich guy using the tax code
in this way and widely speaking avoiding
IRS scrutiny that would be appropriate
for the uh relaxed application of the
tax law that Trump and people like him
use so this is a story about Trump but
it's also a story about the tax code and
a story about the IRS now one question
that you may have is how do you go
negative close to a hundred million
dollars over five years in income and
yet still live the lifestyle that Trump
lives with day-to-day expenses being so
lavish and expensive the private plane
all these different things if you lose
30 million in a year how do you also
have a private plan and all this stuff
the answer is that you are asset Rich
you are asset rich and you can also we
don't fully know because we don't have
the full tax returns yet but you can
borrow against the assets to have money
with which to live that lavish lifestyle
and again it is not unique to Trump if
anything good will come of this it's
that the Trump tax returns will expose
the mechanisms that many rich people use
in order to live lavish Lifestyles but
pay almost no taxes or in some cases no
cases no taxes at all you tell lenders
that your assets are appreciating
dramatically and then they'll give you
girthy huge loans against those assets
which you can then use to live your
lavish lifestyle you tell the IRS these
very same assets are worth nothing I
lost money on these assets let me take a
loss on them give me a tax refund that's
very generally speaking the name of the
game then you live off of the loans you
use the lot the lies to the IRS to claim
a negative income while you're actually
making millions and then you get a tax
refund as well now if uh Donald Trump is
actually as rich as he claims to be
these tax returns don't really make it
look like Trump is super rich
if Trump is really as rich as he claims
to be there's almost certain certainly
criminal level of Fraud and avoidance
that's going on here
um the other possibility is Trump isn't
actually nearly as rich as he claims to
be and we may or may not find that out
the reason Trump clearly fought so hard
to keep his financial records from
becoming public is because he seems to
be the fraud he seems to be not not
quite or nearly as rich as he claims to
be
doing really sketchy stuff with asset
values we've given you the full list
before but the really important takeaway
is it's not just Trump doing this stuff
and there's a question as to whether
it's the tax code or the enforcement
that's the problem and I want to talk
about the IRS component next
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below